So let's actually begin today's lecture.
Um,
which is I've titled Ever at variants
and foolishly jealous intercolonial
relations.
And the,
the quote part of that title ever at
variance and foolishly jealous actually
comes from a colonist named Joseph Warren
who was writing to a friend probably
1766, I think. It doesn't matter.
It's actually the quotes not
highly significant for you,
but the point of it is he was writing to
a friend and what he says to his friend
is,
until the passage of the stamp act,
the colonies had always been quote,
ever at variance and foolishly jealous,
which is kind of going to be the point
of today's lecture ever at variance and
foolishly jealous,
but now with the stamp act,
but people seem to be a
little bit more United.
So today's lecture is the
foolishly jealous part. And um,
on Tuesday we plunge into the stamp act,
which moves us to the more United part
and actually begins a sort of series of
events that are actually going to
build up to a logic of resistance.
So I'm going to be talking today about
basically intercolonial relations about
how people in the different
colonies viewed each other
about how the colonies as
entities interacted with each other.
And towards the end of the lecture,
I'm going to talk about colonial attempts
before the 1760s for them to unite
colonial attempts to unite and act
together. And as we're going to see today,
they weren't really amazingly
successful, those attempts. So,
and there were only three of them
that I'm going to talk about,
but unity is not taken for granted that
I suppose will be one message of today's
lecture. Don't take unity,
colonial unity for granted.
And that's going to lead us up perfectly
to the next lecture on the Stamp Act
crisis,
which is then going to have people
shifting a point of view because of the
crisis at hand. Okay.
So basically in a way,
today's lecture as the third and
last in a series of lectures,
it's really been laying the groundwork
for our immersion into colonial conflict.
So we've looked at the links between
colonists and the mother country.
We looked at aspects of colonial
life and settlement that were kind of
distinctly colonial American.
And now we're sort of laying the last
plank in of the British American mindset
at the time. And that's how the colonies
were relating with each other. Okay.
And I again,
I sort of,
and Freeman's top five tips that I
offered in the introductory lecture that I
gave top five tips towards understanding
the revolution. And I said,
remember contingency.
Um,
and I suppose that's a sort of sub
theme of today's lecture because we,
we so assume the logic and um,
inevitability of a unified nation
at some point down the pike.
I think it's really easy for us to forget
some of the things that I'm going to
be talking about today,
which all add up to unity did not make
sense a lot of the time now I think to
really appreciate ultimately
how significant the first
little glimmerings at
union were.
We first have to understand the vast
differences between the different colonies
and the different regions because
people at the time definitely did.
They were always complaining and remarking
on people from other regions about
how weird they were about
their bizarre manners,
about the weird way they dressed about
their strange attitude constantly.
People from all regions,
all colonies sort of remarking in and not
necessarily favorable way about people
from other places. And I want to start, I
want to offer you a couple examples. Um,
and I want to start with Thomas Jefferson,
who in the seventies and eighties,
um,
devoted some of his energies to
explaining America to a French audience.
And as you'll hear in
some of these quotes,
he's going to definitely be
sounding like a Virginian. Um,
and of course what's interesting to
note about Jefferson is I'll quote him
another time in today's lecture.
Um,
Jefferson strongest remarks about America
or American character are always made
to a foreign audience, right? He
doesn't make them to Americans.
So like notes on the state of Virginia,
which has some remarkable passages in it.
He didn't think that Americans
are going to be reading that.
That was actually for a French audience
and it sorta came back across the ocean.
So a lot of what I'm going
to be quoting here today,
he was not quoting for Americans.
He's actually speaking to the French,
which you can say a lot of blunt
things to the French that you wouldn't
necessarily say to fellow
Americans. So, okay. In 1786,
um, he wrote to a French correspondent
who clearly had written to him in some way
and said, you know, tell
me about America. Um,
so Jefferson writes back,
and I'm going to talk a little bit
about his view of all of the states,
but in this particular instance,
he writes back and says he's very curious
about why Rhode Island is opposed to
every useful preposition. Okay.
Road. I told you about Rhode Island.
I fore warned you about Ra,
Rhode Island.
We have to have a Rhode
Island moment here. Um,
because it appears it's
going to appear again.
I mentioned also the Connecticut
was going to appear again. Um,
Rhode Island was particularly troublesome.
Um,
it was actually the last date to join the
union and it actually joined the union
after the Constitution had
already gone into effect.
So when Washington becomes president
and he goes on his first grant triumphal
tour, oh, I will no, go around the nation
showing everyone that I am president.
He first swing through the north and
he actually refuses to cross the border
into Rhode Island because Rhode Island
is a foreign country and he doesn't want
to go there. Okay. He was making
a kind of strong statement.
Rhode Island wasn't
really happy about this,
but it was their fault because they
hadn't ratified the constitution yet. Um,
a really popular thing to do at the
time in taverns was to drink 12 toasts,
not 13 as a deliberate insult
to Rhode Island. It's like,
so they aren't Rhode Island. Of course
you also get to drink 12 toasts that day.
That's the other happy thing about that.
But at any rate,
so Rhode Island is an issue.
It's going to come up again today even.
So Jefferson was trying
to figure out what is,
what is the deal about Rhode Island
and here is what he explained how he
explains it.
Rhode Island's geography accounts for it.
With the aid of one or two observations,
the cultivators of the earth
are the most virtuous citizens.
It's very Jeffersonian merchants
are the least virtuous.
The ladder reside principally
in the seaport towns,
the former in the interior country.
Now,
what happened then of the territory
constituting Rhode Island and Connecticut,
the part containing the seaports was
erected into a state by itself and called
Rhode Island and that containing of
the interior country was erected into
another state called Connecticut.
For though it has a little sea coast,
there are no good ports in it hands.
It happens that there is
scarcely one merchant in the
whole state of Connecticut.
While there's not a single man in Rhode
Island who was not a merchant of some
sort. I guess probably a
little bit of an exaggeration.
This circumstance has decided
the characters of the two
states and the remedies
to this evil are hazardous.
One would be to consolidate
the two states into one. Right.
That's a really popular idea.
Another would be to banish
from Ireland from the union.
Thank you Thomas Jefferson.
Is Anyone here for Rhode Island?
There are no Rhode Islanders
I bashing safely. Wow.
No one can come get me one time
someone did say, excuse me,
I'm from Rhode Island so I'm safe.
This is dangerous.
Um, so number one, you could consolidate
Connecticut and Rhode Island. Number two,
you could banish what
island from the union.
Number three would be to compel the
submission of Rhode Island to the wheel of
the other states. Right. He
has an issue with Rhode Island,
but Rhode Island has issues. Um,
he's speaking partly as a southerner,
but a lot of other people had
questions about Rhode Island as well.
And about the same time, different
French correspondent, once again,
Jefferson writing about the character
of the northern states and the character
of the southern states.
And Jefferson writes in the north,
they are cool, sober,
laborious, persevering,
independent,
jealous of their own liberties.
And just to those of others interested,
she caning cheating superstitious
and hypocritical and their religion.
Thank you. Thomas Jefferson in the south,
they are firing voluptuary, indolent,
unsteady, independent, zealous
for their own liberties,
but trampling on those of
others. Generous, candid,
without attachment or
pretensions to any religion.
But that of the heart and spoken like
a Virginia and according to Jefferson,
as he explains to this Frenchman and
observing traveler without the aid of a
quadrant,
may always know his latitude
by the character of the
people among whom he finds
himself like he really believes in,
is very different people in the
different colonies and to Jefferson,
Pennsylvania with sort of the perfect
happy medium where the two characters kind
of met and blended and form to people,
which as he put it,
we're free from the extremes,
both of vice and virtue.
Now that's Jeffersonian rhetoric.
There's a lot of Jeffersonian rhetoric.
George Washington,
a man have much fewer words,
put his views about the north a lot
more succinctly. Okay. To Washington,
New Englanders were as he put it in 1777
right when he joined the continental
army and the continental army is in
Massachusetts. Washington joins the army.
He heads up to Massachusetts and the
army is largely made of new Englanders
confronts the army and he
writes to a friend and says,
new Englanders are an exceeding,
dirty and nasty people. Okay,
that's us. Sorry, father of our country.
We didn't live up to his demands.
Now new Englanders to be fair, had
similar feelings about the south. Right?
They thought southerners were
snooty, aristocratic, proud. Um,
I once in a diary came across a passage
in which there's a Pennsylvania and he's
sitting at a dinner table with
some Virginians. And in his diary,
of course he's complaining about this
because he says all they did through the
entire dinner was talk about gambling,
horseracing,
Virginia Ham and drinking and
drinking and drinking and drinking.
And the parents are this Pennsylvania.
I guess that's what Virginia is
gambling and drinking Virginia.
Now, John Adams with a little
bit of a dose of Puritan guilt,
felt that new Englanders were the
best trained in the school of popular
government,
but that they weren't really skilled
and personal relations as he put it.
New Englanders are awkward, bashful,
Pert, ostentatious and vein.
A mixture which excites ridicule and
gives, discussed some part of me,
thinks he was speaking about himself
when he could've been. Southerners.
He claims were skilled at display
and gentlemanly manners. Um,
but according to Adams, they were
habituated to hire notions of themselves.
And the distinction between them
and the common people than we are.
So they're basically snootier
according to John Adams.
So comments like all of
these are reminders about how
very different the sort of
colony countries were from each other.
They did each have different distinctive
characters and maybe equally important.
They often distrusted one another.
So in a sense colonies often had more
of a connection with the mother country
than with each other.
Now this is partly due to
pragmatic concerns like bad roads,
like the fact that there actually was
not a huge bustling amount of inter
colonial trade because colonies really
did focus their trading energies on the
mother country and not
so much with each other.
And then also there were a lot of
border conflicts between colonies,
which caused distrust and complications
between colonies and also help to
discourage trade.
Now the colonies were hostile to each
other because they were seeing to their
own interests,
but also it's kind of reflected in the
comments that I opened the lecture with.
There also was just basic cultural
distrust. Now as I head into this,
it's worth noting that there actually
were three different types of colonies.
There were three different ways
in which colonies were founded,
and these differences could sometimes
affect the structure of the colony and its
relations with the mother country.
So this is going to be very quick and
dirty version of these three kinds of
colonies. Um, type of colony number one,
you had corporate colonies like
Connecticut and Rhode Island, um,
incorporated by puritans
who left Massachusetts and
basically a corporate colony
made its own constitution and it
was then ratified by the king.
So these are independently
founded colonies.
They're clearly independent in spirit,
which makes them potentially troublesome,
not potentially troublesome,
just makes them troublesome. Um,
so corporate colonies is
type of colony number one.
You also had proprietary colonies like
Pennsylvania and Maryland where the king
would give ownership of the
colony to someone. So for example,
William Penn is a
proprietor in Pennsylvania.
Lord Baltimore is the
proprietor in Maryland.
So you have corporate colonies,
you have proprietary colonies.
And the third kind of
colony is a royal colony,
which is owned by the king.
So royal colonies include New York,
South Carolina, North Carolina,
Georgia, and Massachusetts.
It's the whole range of colonies.
I basically haven't named
in those earlier colonies.
A lot of these colonies were royal
colonies. They were owned by the king.
Now of the three,
in some ways,
corporate colonies were the closest
to what would eventually become states
because corporate colonies had
drawn up their own constitution.
They made their own charter
and what that actually means.
And the charter was made by the
people who lived in the colony.
And what that actually means is,
um,
once independent is independence is
declared and all of these newly created
states need to create a new constitution,
which writes out royal authority.
Connecticut kind of had its own little
charter in Rhode Island to, to begin with.
They kind of already there is
little independent entities.
They were a little ahead of the game.
They sort of had their own constitution
that needed a little tweaking.
But really all these other colonies were
sort of starting from scratch. Okay. So,
so those are kind of basic structural
institutional differences between these
three kinds of colonies.
But beyond their basic structure.
There are also things about the social
structure and the culture of the
different regions and colonies
that differentiated them and,
and bread some distrust.
So let's just look for just a few
minutes at the different regions.
And let's start with New England. Now
logically enough, this is not a surprise.
New England had the most structured
institutional base of the colonies because
of its puritan roots. So just think about
the whole idea of the New England town.
And that's what I'm talking about here.
In general,
New England colonies were
divided into townships.
Each township was oriented around
the church. Traditionally speaking,
your church fathers,
where your town fathers,
the church felt responsible not
only for your soul and church,
but also for your soul as
displayed in your everyday life.
So there actually were church officials
who sometimes went from home to home to
be sure that you were living properly
biting by godly standards of living.
And that's, uh, that's sort of really
strong institutional base of settlement.
Now as commerce boomed in New England,
the sort of pure church orientation of
New England society got a little bit
diluted, but still it had an enormous
impact on the tone of life in the northern
colonies.
Also because of new England's puritan
roots and the puritan respect for the word
is presented in the Bible and you needed
to be able to read and understand the
Bible for yourself.
Literacy was particularly high in the
New England colonies and New England
colleges.
Harvard and Yale were generally superior
to most of the other colleges at the
time.
Although King's college in New York,
which is now Columbia and the College
of New Jersey, which is now Princeton,
also ranked high. William
and Mary in Virginia was kind
of in a different league.
And I'm gonna come back to that. Um, and
also to Uva, which is where I got my phd.
I'm in a few minutes now.
New England was mostly mostly
composed of small farms,
supported by family labor.
And there was some slave labor and it
was the least in all of the colonies.
And there were roughly 35 white
Europeans to every one slave
because of its original puritan origins.
So because of its original
focus on excluding all but
the likeminded who shared
their religious sense of purpose,
New England was not really
diverse religiously or ethnically,
and it was this lack of diversity.
You kind of insular nature of New England
society that made many people think of
doing lenders is kind of what their
word for it was unmixed, you know,
sort of stiff and awkward. They're
not used to being out in the world.
They don't know how to have conversations
with people who aren't like them.
You're sort of weird because they
only know other new Englanders.
But the same sort of relative lack of
diversity also allowed new Englanders to
unite quickly and powerfully if they felt
that their rights were being impinged
upon,
as we'll see during the first phases of
the revolution within the next week or
so.
So that's new England,
the middle colonies in at least one
way where the precise opposite of New
England, because they were actually the
most diverse of all of the colonies.
The middle colonies were flooded by
immigrants from Germany, from Ireland,
from Scotland to name just a few
countries. And as a matter of fact,
the middle colonies were considered in
a phrase used at the time the best poor
man's country because there were ample
supplies of land and there weren't harsh
restrictions are great
intolerance of diversity.
And part of the reason why it was so
popular for immigrants is because of the
great tolerance of the
Quakers who founded the colony
though Pennsylvania,
like Massachusetts was founded by
basically a group of religious dissenters.
The Quaker faith was quite different
from puritanism and it was much more
focused on regulating society according
to your internal moral spirit rather
than through institutional sort
of church oriented structures.
So there were fewer external rules and
regulations controlling Pennsylvania
society and there were,
there would have been in New England
and it was a lot easier for people who
arrived in the middle colonies
to adapt to living there.
And tolerance was also integral
to the Quaker faith. So again,
it's easier for immigrants to deal
with arriving to the middle colonies.
Also the middle colonies,
unlike New England and the south were
kind of less of a coherent region and
particularly um,
New York and Pennsylvania,
although they're both lumped
into middle colony enos, um,
they seem to share fewer similarities
and it's why at the time you don't really
hear people dividing the
colonies into thirds.
They do tend to break it into halves and
they do tend to talk about northern or
eastern colonies and southern
colonies and they sort of shove, um,
Pennsylvania north and
shove Maryland south.
Obviously thinking generally about
slavery is a helpful dividing line.
Now that said to people at the time,
New York was particularly problematic
and in some ways some people actually
considered New York to be more southern
than northern Jefferson actually said
that at the time he found the
New York was in the wrong place,
like somehow geographically and ended up
far more north than it should have been.
It should be a southern state.
And what he meant by that was don't
like a lot of other states or colonies
actually not yet states colonies.
It was organized around great land owners
who owned vast expanses of land and
although in all of the colonies that were
sort of great families who controlled
or certainly had a lot of power in
New York politics was really largely
organized around the clash between
a handful of great families and the
Livingston's are the sort of largest and
most noteworthy political clan in New
York.
And I can,
I can vouch to you as a historian of this
time period that when you're studying
and your politics, there are a million
Livingston's and they're all named Philip,
like trying to tell which Livingston he's,
which Livingston is really hard.
There are a lot of Livingston's and they
all have, a lot of them are empower.
Other people commented not necessarily
that New York seems southern but that it
had really high toned manners that
the people were really aristocratic,
that they were very interested in fine
living in display than some of the
surrounding more northern colonies.
And some people considered New Yorkers
shifty self interested in subtle. Um,
there's one account I came across
in which, um, this fellow says,
basically he says he thinks
New Yorkers are all liars,
but the way he puts it in something like
New Yorkers are all guilty of telling
great thumpers I guess a great thumper is
a big lie. And actually
that same diary, okay, this,
this really surprised
me. I suppose. You know,
very often this is true with
slang to you consider slang or,
or other things as being really,
really modern.
And then you discover it actually isn't
really modern. It dates all the way back.
I found a letter once from this time
period in which someone said I wanted to
give so and so a good swift
kick in the can. Right. Okay.
I don't expect someone to say that in
1799 a good swift kick in the can like the
Cam, like they're saying
that. And so I don't know,
that's a little sort of more cash than
I thought they would be in 1799. Um,
but so in this diary account, um,
this person is talking about New York,
he's a Pennsylvania and,
um,
he says New Yorkers talk really fast,
walk really fast,
they do everything
really fast in New York.
They're sort of really business
like and abrupt. I mean,
I'd actually just doesn't
sound very different from
what someone today would say
visiting New York City for the first
time. Um, but he also describes,
and now I'm going to
embarrass myself fully. Um,
he also describes what he calls the
New York walk, which in his mind,
like he thinks all New
Yorkers walk this way,
which I guess is kind of like
bent over and walking very fast.
So in his,
and he does a little limitation of it.
Apparently in his diary he talks about
it. So, so he's looking at New York,
basically his,
his impression,
you almost could read someone today making
a very similar observation about New
York. So New York, Pennsylvania,
middle colonies, but different, um,
considering though these differences
between New York and Pennsylvania,
years later after the
constitution kicks in,
they actually become an enormous issue
because they'd begin to play into the
question of where the national
capital should be located.
Because the general belief at the time
was wherever the capitol ended up being
located would determine the manners of
the national office holders and thus
determine the sort of manner and
character of the nation, right?
So wherever you're living is
going to shape how you act.
So the national office holders are
going to act if they're in New York,
kind of snooty.
And then the American public's going to
look at these snooty people and they're
going to try to act
like the snooty people.
And that's all of America will
become an aristocratic and corrupt.
And that's the end of the Republican
experiment in government Dar. Right?
So that was kind of the logic at the time.
So people had a lot of attitudes about
whether the capital should be in New York
or should be in Philadelphia.
Actually in Pennsylvania.
The idea being that Pennsylvania seemed
more ideal because it's sort of in the
middle,
it seems kind of balanced.
People said it seemed the most small r
Republican meaning sort of virtuous and
straightforward and uncorrupted.
So it's not as though these issues die
out when we get states in a country.
But now southerners might
disagree and might say no.
Pennsylvania is of course
not the most Republican.
We in the south are the most Republican,
um,
the most virtuous of all regions.
Um,
of course other colonists from other
would have disagreed and what it's claimed
as many did that the south
was aristocratic in the
extreme that they had a true
hottie aristocratic,
elite plantation owners and
then a glut of poor common folk.
Not surprisingly, this is not
going to be surprise to anyone.
Southern Society was structured
around widely scattered plantations,
which essentially functioned like
small villages owned and controlled by
southern gentlemen.
And it was these gentlemen who controlled
and regulated affairs who did things
like take responsibility for fixing roads
or or tending to local affairs rather
than having some kind of
formal institution tending
to those things as might've
happened in a place that was
more structured institutionally
structured like New
England and the southern gentleman
really did enjoy great display in their
homes, in their clothing,
in their style of living.
They spent their leisure time
gambling, cockfighting, horseracing,
and as that diary suggests drinking.
Now generally speaking,
education was not as important
in the south is in the north.
There's just not to say gentlemen,
we're expected to be educated.
They were in the south,
but going to school at William and Mary
with sometimes more social training than
intellectual training. I'm sorry, William
and Mary, I do not mean to insult you,
but for one,
Thomas Jefferson was really not impressed
with his education at William and Mary
and ultimately he created in his old age,
the University of Virginia because he
wanted to create what he considered to be
a better academic institution in the
state of Virginia where people would be
truly learning. This will be a temple of
Learning University of Virginia. Okay.
Things didn't work out the way he planned
initially. The University of Virginia,
um, there was a lot of
drinking, a lot of gambling. Um,
I think,
I can't remember whether Edgar Allan Poe
was thrown out for drinking or gambling
or both,
but he was expelled from the University
of Virginia for doing one or both of
those two things. Um,
students really liked at Uva.
I don't know if any of
you have been there,
but there's sort of this beautiful
lawn at the center of campus. Um,
students really liked to ride up and
down the lawn on their horses and shoot
guns off in the air. This
is a popular hobby. Um,
things got really bad apparently
with the guns and the horses.
So I'm Thomas Jefferson in 1825 called
a meeting of the faculty and students so
that he could reprimand them.
You know,
this is like the hobby and delight
of his old age. You know, his,
what he's going to give to his
own colony or state of Virginia.
And now there's like wacky people
riding around shooting guns.
And not really going to class per se.
So he calls this meeting of students
and faculty and he invites along.
James Monroe and James Madison.
Okay.
So we got three ex presidents who are
standing over the Virginia student body
who are going to reprimand
them or shooting off their
guns. And it supposedly,
I always find this sort of touching right?
Supposedly Thomas Jefferson
stood up to yell at the students,
but he was so upset at what was happening
at the university that he started to
cry and he had to sit down
crying founders,
you know, so he was very upset.
And then one of the genes is,
I don't know if it was Madison and Monroe
Sorta had to take over now you would
think that a crying founder might like
help the student body in Virginia to kind
of shape up, but it did not.
Um, and years later, uh,
when faculty told the still riding gun
shooting students that they needed to
actually give up their guns now because
they apparently just didn't want to stop
shooting them. There was some kind of
a gun riot, like, like a riot, like,
like crashing windows and I don't
know the details, but it was ugly.
And 70 students were expelled.
Great.
Four years after the amazing gun riot.
It's when students were celebrating
the anniversary of the gun riot,
which kind of tells you that the people
being expelled really didn't do a lot.
This gets really unfortunate. They were
celebrating the anniversary of the gun.
Right. And a professor was
accidentally shot and killed.
So, um, it's a problem.
It's Uva the early years, right?
It's like, it's, it's problem.
Unfortunate problem with the guns.
Okay.
Virginia education in the early years.
So as with the other regions,
southern colonists,
colonies were distinctive in many ways
other than crazy gun toting students. Um,
of course slavery had an enormous
impact on the Telenav life in the south.
Um,
there were between 1.3 and 1.7 white
Europeans to every slave in the south.
And in some colonies like South Carolina,
there actually was a black
majority to Jefferson. Slavery,
corrupted the morals of the south.
Um,
and once again he says this and notes
on the state of Virginia to his French
audience.
Um,
so he certainly writes things there
that he would not have sent to a fellow
Virginia.
And in this case,
this is what he writes and notes there
must outlets be an unhappy influence on
the manners of our people produced
by the existence of slavery among us,
the whole commerce between master and
slave as a perpetual exercise of the most
boisterous passions, the most
unremitting despotism on the one part,
and degrading submissions on the other.
Our children see this and learn to
imitate it for man is an imitative animal.
The parents storms,
the child looks on,
puts on the same errors in
the circle of smaller slaves,
gives a loose to his worst of passions
and thus nursed educated and daily
exercise. And tyranny cannot but be
stamped by it with odious peculiarities.
The man must be a prodigy who can retain
his manners and morals and depraved by
such circumstances.
So that's Jefferson notes on the state
of Virginia and a really strong passage
about the influence of slavery on the
morals and manners of southerners.
So clearly the south is based on the
mastery literally and figuratively of a
ruling elite.
And it's this spirit of um,
entitlement and independence and
mastery that would inspire some of the
emotional response in the
south to Britain's actions
in the 1760s and seventies
seventies particularly in Virginia,
which was the colony that really
believe itself to be at the top of the
hierarchy of southern colonies,
the leader of the south,
the response of Virginia to what they
perceive to be the impingement of Britain
upon their rights was second in intensity
as we're going to see only to what
took place in Massachusetts
and particularly in Boston.
So you can now begin to see how really
diverse these different regions and
colonies were.
And you can also be good to see why when
different men from different regions
came together and something like
ultimately a continental congress,
they were pretty quick to
pick up on those differences.
And New Englanders picked apart the
southerners as being arrogant and wearing
flashy clothes and southern or southern
new Englanders were strange and awkward
and everybody distrusted the New
Yorkers and everybody smiled at the
Pennsylvania ones.
But all of these things were pretty
prominent in any kind of a continental
organization.
So with all of these big differences you
can begin to see how truly amazing and
noteworthy would have been any
attempts at colonial unity.
And what I'm going to do right now is
just talk very briefly about these three
attempts, a colonial unity that I
mentioned at the outset of the lecture,
two of them as we'll see,
we're inspired by the colonies
as a means of self defense.
One of them was basically
created by the British,
not surprisingly as a means
of asserting British control,
but what's really most important to
note in these examples that I'm going to
offer you here is generally speaking,
when American colonists considered
colonial union on their own,
it was for reasons of self defense.
It was for reasons of self interest and
not because of some greater ideological
colleague.
It was really for basic self defense.
So let's look at the first
attempt at colonial union,
which took place in 1643 okay.
So in 1643 representatives of the
colonies of Massachusetts Bay,
Plymouth, Connecticut, and new haven and
new haven is its own little settlement.
I let it happened several times in this
course that new haven just appears all
by itself,
which I always kind of love cause you
just don't expect it to sort of sit there
all by itself having historical
prominence. But here it
is. So Massachusetts Bay,
Plymouth,
Connecticut and new haven decided that
they wanted to form a confederation to
defend themselves against Dutch expansion
and hostile Indian tribes and to
create some kind of forum for
resolving intercolonial disputes,
which happened all the time.
Rhode Island tried to join the forum,
but it was excluded because
nobody trusted Rhode Island.
They were not invited to join the union
known as the United Colonies of New
England or the New England Confederation
didn't have any sanction in the
charters of its member colonies.
Instead it was just the kind of joint
advisory council and it was made up of two
members from each participating colony.
So basically it had eight people in it
and six of the eight had to vote for
something for it to take effect.
So between 1643 and 1664,
the United colonies of New England or
the New England confederation met between
those years, 60, 43 and 1664 until
Connecticut annex to new haven.
And the number of members decreased right
down to six and this became a problem.
So after 1664 when new haven's
or merged with Connecticut, um,
it didn't meet very often.
And then ultimately in 1684,
it kind of drifted to an end, the end
of the United colonies of New England.
So that's amazing.
First Attempt at union wasn't attempt.
The second union of a sort with
spurred by the British government,
which in the 1680s became worried
that the new England colonies were not
sympathetic and loyal to the British
monarch. And we're, we're basically,
we're creeping up here on, I'm not going
to go into it in any detail, but um,
what comes to be known as the glorious
revolution when the monarchy fall.
So there's a reason why they're wondering
how loyal the new Englanders are to
the monarchy.
But British authorities wanted to be
sure that the new England colonies were
going to be loyal to the British monarch.
So in 1686 the British government formed
what they called the dominion of New
England, which to me sounds like sort
of Darth Vader, Star Wars, the dominion.
So they formed with the dominion of New
England 1686 which fused all of the New
England colonies plus New York Plus New
Jersey into one colony to be ruled by
one royal governor and
an appointed counsel. I.
That's a dramatic gesture.
The resulting mass that was made by
merging all of that into one colony was
larger in size than England.
It's a lot of land,
a lot of land.
The newly installed world governor
was named Edmund Androse, a n,
d R. O. S.
Androse ruled over the dominion without
a legislature passing laws after they
were approved by a
majority of his counselors.
You can see how happy this is going to
make the new Englanders. Not surprisingly,
a lot of new Englanders
resented the domain Ian,
and the way it just sort of supplanted
colonial legislature's even more
unfortunate and was not a
very diplomatic politician.
And he really had no
reason to be diplomatic.
He was sent to New England
on Royal Authority.
His job was to assert royal authority,
so he really didn't need to please
anybody except the king even.
So he somehow seemed intent on really
proving his authority by flaunting it
before new Englanders.
So for example,
not long after he arrived and rose
took over a puritan meeting house and
converted it into an Anglican Church,
right? Nothing like a little new parents.
You think you control the dominion.
But I control the
dominion dramatic gesture.
He also put the colonial militia under
the direct control of the governor
himself. And there are a number of other
highly unpopular things that he did.
But in 1689 when the Stuart
monarchy fell in England,
because of the glorious revolution,
American colonists also revolted.
And they toppled the dominion government.
They jailed it's officers,
including Androse, who supposedly
tried to escape in women's clothing.
Okay. So that's somewhat
humiliating, even more humiliating.
He was caught for it and rose and he was
eventually freed and not surprisingly
fled right back to England.
And soon after Britain just let the
colonies resumed their former status.
So end of the dominion of New England.
That's a really obviously
whopping big success.
The third and last attempt at union
is in 1754 and like the first one,
it was largely because of a threat.
And this time colonies were afraid of
threats coming from the French and from
Indians.
And here we have the not really promising
entry of George Washington onto the
colonial military scene.
I'm going to draw a little picture too,
of George Washington's moment of
glory at this moment in time. Okay.
So in 1753 1754 there were some skirmishes
on the Pennsylvania frontier because
French forces were moving south from
Quebec and Virginia militia under the
command of George Washington a young. And
as we will hear, inexperienced officer,
he sent out by the governor of Virginia
to investigate and see what's happening
with the sort of fringe
movements on the frontier.
So Washington and this man apparently
tramp around the frontier for a while and
ultimately they find a small party of
French soldiers in an encampment and they
opened fire on them and kill a
lot of them. And then discover,
unfortunately after the fact that actually
it was a neutral ambassador holding
papers for negotiation and
his diplomatic escort. Okay.
So Washington just killed a bunch of
diplomats on their escort and the diplomat
literally died clutching like
papers to negotiate a, okay,
thank you George Washington.
So Washington and after this glorious
moment decides he's going to,
he's going to pull back and he's going
to encamp his troops in a fort that he
will have built. Right. So he
has his troops build a fort,
he names it fort necessity, which it
really was right. He just killed people.
He should have been killing.
Now we'd better create a forge.
So he creates fort necessity.
But unfortunately for Washington he
built it in basically in a valley.
Okay. Fort in valley, just not good.
He didn't really think very hard about
the places up above the fort where the
French could perch and fire down into the
fort, which of course they did. Right.
He also didn't think about the fact
that if it's in a valley, if it rains,
it's really bad for people in the valley.
So sure enough,
the French attack there
is a big rainstorm.
The French are shooting down from the
heights and Washington and his little
troop are down in this sort of soggy,
increasingly puddled fort in which their
powder is all getting soaked in these
huge puddles as it continues to reign.
This did not end well for Washington
and basically he ultimately had to
surrender.
Not only did he have to surrender,
but because of the document that
was really badly translated,
he signed his name to terms of surrender,
which announced that Washington had
quote assassinated a French diplomat,
like, yes, I assassinated. This
was all bad, like it was just,
this is George Washington's entry,
right? Let's give the command to him.
This is not a good moment for George.
And in addition to that,
supposedly in this moment,
Washington wrote a letter to his brother.
He was still kind of cheery about this
whole thing throughout this whole thing.
Um, he wrote a letter to
his brother and he said,
I have to quote it precisely here.
I heard bullets whistle and believe me,
there was something charming in the sound,
right?
He's so excited about
getting a chance to fight.
He's like the charming sound of bullets.
Supposedly that quote made its way
back to King George the second,
who thought it was a really stupidly
ridiculous thing for anybody to say.
And I think what the king said was
something along the lines of he wouldn't
think so if he'd heard very many
of those bullets with Lincoln,
what they would not be charming anymore.
So not a good moment for George. Um,
he's not helping matters.
But in addition to that,
the British really were worried. The
Indian relations, generally speaking,
were deteriorating largely
due to complications between
colonies that weren't
cooperating with each other.
So the governors of Massachusetts and
New York persuade the British lords of
trade. They're the guys who regulate trade
in the colonies to issue a call for a
conference to meet in Albany in June of
1754 to negotiate with the six nations
with the Iroquois
Confederation Confederation,
and to talk about other ways of
coordinating defense for the colonies.
So in 1754 there's this meeting call
to figure out a way for the colonies to
jointly work things out
with the native Americans.
The six nations invitations
went to nine colonies,
Massachusetts, New Hampshire,
New York, New Jersey,
Pennsylvania, Maryland, Virginia,
Rhode Island, and Connecticut.
I'll, I'll repeat that one more time.
Massachusetts, New Hampshire, New York,
New Jersey, Pennsylvania, Maryland,
Virginia, Rhode Island, Connecticut. Um,
North Carolina,
South Carolina and Georgia
were not included because
they were probably just too
far away from where people thought
there was going to be conflict north,
New Jersey and Virginia declined
because it was too expensive to go.
So even here when you, people are
afraid there's an Indian threat,
some colonies just say, yeah, it cost too
much. I don't think I'm going to bother.
But this meeting,
I'll end here and I'll pick up with
this little end passage on a Tuesday.
This meeting came to be
known as the Albany Congress,
the Albany Congress in 1754 and I'll
talk briefly on Tuesday about the Albany
Congress and what it was and what it did,
and then I'll segue from that,
which also doesn't end
well into the stamp act.